is a Ben Cohen Ben Cohen he's a big-time
sports reporter Wall Street Journal Ben
you might want to bail on this you might
not want to be affiliated with this it's
guilt by association but welcome to the
program author of the hot hand available
wherever books are sold we'll talk about
that coming up I noticed you've written
a little bit about the coronavirus where
where do you think the tipping point is
going to be sports-wise with the
coronavirus I think it's gonna be a
digital eye for a hot-dog-eating contest
no III I do think it's coming I mean to
me this whole thing is a bit like
watching the Titanic approach the
iceberg in slow motion like we know
what's going to happen we know it's
going to be very painful and yet people
on the deck haven't really wrap their
minds around it yet I don't think I mean
the idea of playing games and empty
stadiums was unrealistic not too long
ago but it's already become reality in
Asia and Europe and there's nothing
really about being in the u.s. that
inoculates us from this we need to be a
few weeks behind Asia in Europe I think
in terms of the spread of this virus and
so it would not really surprise me in
the least
to see extreme measures being enforced
here or pretty soon I think there's a
real possibility for severe disruptions
at like the busiest time of the calendar
for American sports but I also wonder
about this Ben the NCAA is slow-moving
you've got the final flower the final
Ford coming up in April and I wonder if
they would have the wherewithal to be
the first league that would make a
really dramatic decision and have these
basketball games played you know in in
front of empty arenas well I think the
Final Four is not the issue I mean
that's a hundred thousand people in a
football stadium but the thing about the
Final Four is that it's a month away and
I think that the NBA and the NHL will
probably have moved by then it seems
like they're probably going to move at
some point this week I mean it just
feels like the momentum is heading that
way so you know that the NCAA has to
worry about first-round games first
right I mean so that's next week I mean
there are conference tournaments this
weekend Vanderbilt has sent kids home
and and and canceled classes and yet the
SEC Tournament is is down the street in
Nashville so
the NCAA is not the most progressive
body I don't know if you were aware of
that and I think there will probably
have to be some pressure from local
authorities and states and maybe even
you know on the federal level and you
know I I don't know what they are going
to do I mean the idea of playing the
NCAA tournament
in empty arenas is very strange right
but it's a little bit different from the
NBA playoffs because these are neutral
site games anyway so there's not a home
court advantage that either team has I
think it would just be weird more than
anything I mentioned that you wrote the
book the hot hand it's available online
wherever books are sold and I was
fascinated by this because it was a
couple of decades ago I did a story at
ESPN it was called getting blue or
getting in the zone as athletes called
getting blue or in the zone and I
remember talking to Dennis Eckersley and
I said what's that feeling like and he
said I can't describe it he goes I don't
want to talk about it because I'll talk
myself out of it but you've written a
book about really getting in the zone
here the hot hand so explain to the
audience what the initiative or the
premise was behind writing this yeah so
you know there's really no singular
definition of the hot hand but I like to
think of it as when success leads to
more success and in basketball for
example it's always been studied in
basketball and that's when you make one
shot in a row and then another and then
another and you feel like you're going
to make your next shot right you can't
miss you're in the zone you're on fire
but what makes this really interesting
is that a few decades ago there was this
classic study about the hot hand and
what made it a classic was the
counterintuitive conclusion that there
is no such thing as the hot hand it
doesn't exist
it's simply seeing patterns in
randomness it was this cognitive bias
this easily digestable example of seeing
patterns and randomness and you know
once that study came out something kind
of amazing happened which is that nobody
believed it the athletes themselves
none of us because we'd all felt the hot
hand we'd seen the hot hand for
ourselves now some of this has changed
in recent years there are some evidence
to suggest that our intuition actually
may have been right all along but to me
like the reason I was so intrigued by
this was that it was a story that has
genius scholars and Nobel Prize winners
and NBA superstars
and it was really about something that
we all thought to be true only to be
told that it wasn't only to realize that
maybe it actually was and that was just
irresistible to me as a story but is
there such thing as home court advantage
like is that is that something is that
real where you have somebody who wins so
many games in a row at home well I think
yes that typically there are clearly
advantages to playing at home right
teams are are better at home this is a
little bit different right because we
all if this is sort of like personal
right it's it's individual it's not a
team thing and I think the real thing
here is one of control like there's
something amazing happens when we do
feel hot whether it's in basketball
whether it's in life I'm sure you felt
hot behind the mic sometimes right there
are just times when you're in a zone and
the question has always been like is
that real or is that an illusion and I
think it's something that we are still
trying to figure out I'm still thinking
about it even after spending all these
years writing about it but you have
athletes who try to put themselves in
the zone can you can you physically do
that I don't think so in fact I asked
Steph Curry about this because in the
book I write about the one night that
Steph Curry was the hottest he's ever
been was really a game that changed his
life and the fate of the Golden State
Warriors and the future of the entire
NBA and was a game against the Knicks in
2013 the most amazing part about it is
that the Knicks actually won the game
but no matter that I asked Steph like is
is there anything that you can do to put
yourself in the zone and he says he
doesn't know when it's going to happen
or where it's going to happen or how
it's going to happen or why it's going
to happen but once it does happen you
have to embrace it and he did that night
he scored 54 points he made 11 of his 13
threes it was kind of the game that
changed everything for him and for us
and for you know everybody who watches
basketball
what about gambling where you feel like
you're on a roll literally on a roll or
roulette or you know craps does it does
it play into that as well
um well we think it does something odd
happens when we walk into a casino when
we go to a basketball arena and Steph
Curry makes three shots in a row
everybody thinks that he's going to make
his fourth shot right that's the hot
hand when we walk into a casino and you
go to a roulette wheel and the ball
read three times in a row what research
has shown is that people bet on black
the next time that's the opposite of the
hot hand it's called the gamblers
fallacy and to me again this is about
control when we have agency of a
situation when we are the shooters and
when we are playing basketball we think
we can get hot but when we understand
that we were at the mercy of chance we
realize that we probably can't and so
the difference there is like a skilled
performance and random performance
skilled is when you can really take
advantage and random is when you
probably shouldn't and believing in the
hot hand can be disastrous it can
backfire on you and burn you a little
bit do you know more after you've done
this or less after you've done this that
is a great question I technically know
more about the hot hand but it sort of
made me question everything around me so
it's possible that I just spent like
three years becoming less smart about
something which is always a great way to
spend three years
give me the athlete that you would love
to talk to about this about the hot hand
well I you know it was Steph and I did
get to talk to him we saw LeBron talk
about it a few weeks ago after he made
five threes and like seven possessions
and he says of course the hot hand is
real which makes him like every other
NBA player and it actually might be klay
Thompson just because you never quite
know what's going to come out of Klay
Thompson's mouth and he I think like you
know I wrote about Steph but probably
the guy who embodies the hot hand is his
own teammate right like to score 37
points in a quarter is still an insane
achievement and I've watched that that
YouTube clip over and over and I know
those shots are going in and I still
have no idea how he actually does it so
I would love to like insert some truth
serum into him and just like just grill
Klay for like an hour about like what
that feels like then good luck with the
book we appreciate you joining us thank
you Dan that's Ben Cohen Wall Street
Journal sports reporter and author of
the hot hand yeah I remember Jordan